we have new details about this accident
that took the life of cinematographer
helena hutchins and injured the movie's
director now alec fired the fatal shot
but this isn't the first time a prop gun
has misfired on a movie set
we have two people accidentally shot on
a movie set by a prop gun we need help
immediately
we were rehearsing and it went off and i
ran out we all ran out
alec who broke down in tears outside the
sheriff's department in new mexico
shared his shock and sadness this
morning adding he's quote fully
cooperating with the police
investigation to address how this
tragedy occurred
so what went wrong e.t has obtained an
email sent by the union which covers
prop masters describing the shooting as
an accidental weapons discharge in which
a live single round was accidentally
fired on set by the principal actor
hitting both the director of photography
helena hutchins who died at a nearby
hospital and director joel souza i'm
very concerned personally about how
something like this was able to occur
firearms expert stephen gutowski says
it's possible someone mixed up blank
rounds with live rounds physically the
difference between a blank round and a
live round is is very noticeable clearly
there must have been a serious breach in
safety protocols for this to have
happened
just hours before the shooting alec
posted this picture of himself on the
set of rust in costume and with a fake
wound on his stomach he described being
back on location as exhausting
the 63 year old actor has had a lot of
experience handling firearms in movies
we counted at least 11 films including
mission impossible fallout and the hunt
for red october
as the investigation continues in new
mexico we're learning more about the
victims the 48 year old director was
released from the hospital this morning
and the film's director of photography
42 year old helena hutchins it's a
passion for sure on tuesday she posted
this video riding horses on set the
ukrainian-born cinematographer is
married and has an eight-year-old son
her husband told the daily mail baldwin
has been in touch and is being very
supportive actor joe manganiello who
worked with helena on the movie
archenemy said i can't believe that this
could happen in this day and age this
morning nichelle spoke to wayne brady
who praised helena's professionalism
they worked together on the 2020 movie
blind fire she carried herself with a
grace but a strength the director
listened to her you know the stars
listened to her because she knew what
she was talking about one of the things
that breaks my heart reading this is
seeing she's a wife and she's a mama
yeah
that's that's heartbreaking to have your
mother taken from you in an instant
unfortunately this isn't hollywood's
first fatal onset gun accident well it
is a violent film it's a very violent
film
i got shot
each one of these
is a life
overnight the sister of the crow star
the late brandon lee shannon lee tweeted
her condolences adding no one should
ever be killed by a gun on a film set
period
don't worry about it
back in 1993 et was on set with brandon
son of the late legend bruce lee only
weeks before his co-star fired a handgun
that was believed to be loaded only with
blanks but the tip of a dummy bullet was
lodged inside hitting brandon in the
abdomen and killing him at night the
barrel i don't believe was checked from
what i saw
whatever happens happens less than 10
years earlier another handgun accident
killing actor john eric hexham on the
set of cover-up hexham accidentally shot
himself in the head with a 44 magnum
being used as a prop gun i play a
x-green beret it was all about weapons
and martial arts and everything
one report from the set of russ says
that in the immediate aftermath of the
accident alec kept asking why he was
handed a hot gun as we mentioned the
vintage prop gun did have a live single
round in it according to the la times a
crew member reported a half a dozen
camera department workers had walked off
the set that morning to protest working
conditions quote corners were being cut
and they brought in non-union people so
they could continue shooting adding that
on saturday there were two misfires on
the prop gun and one the previous week
professional movie armor and weapons
handler mike tristano spoke to et via
phone he worked with alec on 1999's
thickest thieves where baldwin regularly
handled guns he was very professional
very safe very conscientious never had a
problem with him
he was always very safe despite this
photo showing a safety meeting happening
on the russ set mike says proper
procedures were likely not followed the
gun should never have been loaded and
given to an actor during rehearsal
[Music]
you